hello guys today we have
2012 uh honda odyssey
we're gonna add key uh we got
look at the key right here the original
one and uh we're gonna add one of these
keys right here
so uh i will pause the video and uh
we'll come back again
okay guys we cut the keys and uh
let's turn the card off and the new keys
is not programmed yet
nothing's working let's go ahead and
program it
and emo
search honda
all right honda
all right selection people let's see
and you'll see
you know those little blurry you cannot
see it
all right and obviously
right here
and 2012 social is gonna be in this
range
all right you connect our key
what we have here mechanical all right
mechanical key
add one key
okay insert uh register key and switch
ignition on
the ignition is on all right so
let's uh hit okay
connecting switching to our off and 15
[Music]
switch ignition on switch ignition off
for 17 seconds
switch ignition on with the new key
so we're going to put the key on switch
ignition on
pull the mission off
switch ignition on
[Music]
switch ignition off
switching this on
[Music]
as a mobilizer light off i don't see any
mobilizer
so hit ok
switch ignition off
switch ignition on
[Music]
switch ignition off
okay account programmer for
each your insurance start the vehicle
okay switch ignition on
hit okay program complete okay
so let's see
all right as you can see
the car the new one store the vehicle
let's throw the vehicle
there you go
well it takes around three minutes and a
half it shouldn't take that long
it's only supposed to be two minutes all
right so all the key
is still working there you go
so that's the original key and the new
key
[Applause]
all right all right thank you
all right guys see you in the next video
thank you thank you for watching